randy
is with us in hanover massachusetts hi
randy how are you
doing great how about yourself better
than i deserve what's up
so um just have a question um my wife
and i just recently
um got into a business um
business and we're making more money
than we've ever
imagined in our life uh wow good for you
what are you making
no it's it's a it's a true blessing and
we're
super grateful and and know just god has
continued to bless uh our family
how much are you making i mean from
excuse me
how much are you making um
let's uh uh probably
this year we'll talk uh this year we'll
probably do more than 500. wow
good for you man congratulations no
thank you thank you thank you um but
again we're we come
from uh i did the military for a long
time so we had that and then so
come from very humble um beginnings and
so now that we're making this income
we follow a budget but we give ourselves
a very
um i can't think of the word but we just
give ourselves a very modest budget
and we feel bad spending money and at
this point we're just like
we put all this money to the side and
we're like we're giving we're putting in
for retirement we're doing this type of
thing saving up for our kids college
fund
um what else should we be looking to do
with this very good job well done
well done well randy chris and i have
worked with professional athletes and
artists and so forth over the years and
other just uber successful people with
huge incomes
and um many of them struggle with this
because most people didn't start out
with this and by the way thank you for
your service to the country
and i'm glad that you are uh have become
uber successful with your income
and so what we teach people to do is
come up with a basic
budget not a modest budget but a basic
budget
like we were with a football player a
while back chris and i were sitting
there and we just got a yellow pad we
just did it right quick
and uh he's like you know he's kind of a
tightwad guy he didn't want to spend any
money
and he's making serious bank and we said
all right
what is a good budget and he said oh
fifty thousand dollars a year and i went
no dude you're making millions
shut up okay 50 000 you're stupid you
need to
have a better budget than a budget where
you can have a decent
enjoyable life without and you can do
the funding of the retirement funding of
the kids college
you can you know re-purchase a car every
so often what's the budget i think we
ended up with him we finally got him up
to 120 thousand
ten thousand dollars a month pulled some
teeth but we got him there but he was
like he's like making like 800 900 grand
a year right right
right same as your situation so we set a
basic budget
and this is what sharon and i do by the
way as well
because we've got a good income and so
we set a basic budget
like that and then we run our household
on that
then everything above that we apply
a percentage formula to it um we're
christians so we put 10 percent tithe
the government takes 40 percent so
that's half of it
okay the other 50 we spread across
three things uh lifestyle
increase in other words fun money
extra generosity outrageous generosity
and extra investing
so you got 40 for taxes above your
budget you're going to give away 10
that leaves you 50 so divide that 50 up
and spend something on uh
extra fun so here's an example
if you put 10 on extra lifestyle
that would give you your regular
household budget and 50 grand to blow
on cars trips or whatever
okay and that leaves you still 40
to invest and to split up among
outrageous generosity so every time i
get a check from a publisher i got one
today
total money makeover check came in today
and that's always a good day
and uh that check came in today so um
you know
what i'll do is it's real simple i just
apply that formula to it 10
times 40 for taxes has to be set over
for him think about it then i'm gonna
put my percentage on investing
my percentage on increased generosity
and a percentage
uh on uh increased lifestyle and what
you'll be amazed is is that you actually
get to enjoy
the money on the increased lifestyle the
giving you'll be
uh you'll be thinking about it more
because it's allocated it's already kind
of like doing a budget it's already
spent
and so when we do that it frees people
up it really does and randy it'll free
you up too my friend
and i think you and your wife sitting
down and making that list of goals
of the things you're looking to do or
maybe the trips you're looking to go on
what it'll do is it'll it'll help you
kind of get out of your head and get
onto paper and say hey
this is what we're excited about or the
room in the home that you're going to
renovate or whatever it is
it makes it more practical and it makes
it more exciting
yeah i got a buddy of mine that's uh
building habitat houses
out of his outrageous generosity and so
every time he gets a big old check he
gets more excited because that's that
many more habitat houses he can do
and see that that formula i just use
will work with five million a year it'll
work with 500 thousand a year
right no i love it thank you so much i
appreciate that
and uh we were just talking about last
night um dreaming in hd
talk recently um trying to trying to set
up that date where we can dream in hd
and yeah
really what you're doing now is a
different level of dreaming
yeah okay this is now legacy dreaming
some people are dreaming about when
they're out of debt that they finally
get to go on a vacation
okay you're way beyond that we're
talking about completely changing your
family tree
massive amounts of money into some a
couple of ministries to completely
reshape your community
with your generosity i mean you like you
talk about a guy who starts building
multiple habitat houses this is a guy
that's fired up
okay or you know you start buying
tractor trailer loads of bicycles to
give away in the
you know in inner city area where people
are struggling with a ministry there
and and it's not two bikes it's you're
starting to do stuff with scale
because you've got the capacity to be
outrageously generous
outrageously change your legacy and uh
you know it works beautifully hang on
i'm gonna send you a copy of the last
book i did which was a legacy journey
which is all about living in that level
of thinking and it's a different place
to get your brain works differently it
really is and for those of you out there
you're hearing him say
dreaming in hd i talked about that in my
first book retire inspired dreaming in
high definition
like you can see the details in a high
definition tv i want you to see those
kind of definitions in your dream
but we can't just dream we got a plan so
go over to my website chrishogan360.com
and i'll talk to you about having that
dream meeting but i'll also show you the
riq
which is the retire inspired quotient
free tool to help you identify how much
you're going to need to live those
dreams
yeah it's important and and i think what
i'm pointing out there
is chris um you know what happens is
as you reach different levels of wealth
the first one is just to get debt free
so you can breathe right
i'm debt-free you do your scream right
then you got your emergency fund
your dreams start to change yes because
for so long we lived just hand to mouth
in survival yep
and your dream was friday yes you know
yeah and then your dream starts to be
christmas
and then your dream starts to be you
know i i'm paying cash for the kids
college
and then your dream starts to be you
know and then your dream starts to be
and then because and they should move
but at different levels because
otherwise
you you know you don't have anything to
reach for and you get bored that's
exactly right